A
WEEKEND AS EYHT FORCES.
IT'S ANTAINIAN AN SAYHEFTING..Ep
2,000 ETERS RECAPTUREDUKst ISIDO
A COUNTEOFNSE E E
SPECTACULARLASTERN
WHERE A SE C
.SEEN OR THE SEF  FEWECE URS UKF
A A
IT T PICTURES BEING POSTED
HE SYSTEREMING PEOPLE B LIBATBY
WHAT WE'RE HEARINGHEE  OF TROOPS
MOTW TAKING THIS SATUR AND EXTME
FROE VERY
FAST ADVANCE I ORY OF VERY LITT
OPPOSITE. OF SOMELA
HAVING BEEN TAKEWITHOUT
STRUGGLE AT SOME RUSSIOLDIERS S
IN
UN
BORDER  BY THE RUN BORDER ALE T
BORDER OF SOME O
BUALLYUIE G UKRAINIAN
IN THE FACE OFBL IN
TH
THWND THE FEAR IS WH
G TORUFT
HI
PAM?
>>H, UNDERSTDA
THERE.BELL IIN T
YOU FOR THAT.
YESTERDAINE'ESIDENT VOLO CNN'SA
ABOUT THMICES
UKRAINE MAN RECENTT ABT HT.
THAT UKRAIN
MONG IN KHERIN
S OF T EAST.
IS
AI TO
THHE20.E THEE CUAL IS TOR WHOL
BIT.
CALL I WAY.BAL I WLD
INSTILL.HIS
>>NI CNNAR GDUMOVING
E C
TALAND.
BOTTOM LIN I
TUR
>> PAMELA, I THINK IT ATURNINP
THE REASON FOR THAT IS IT'S ALL
N E BATTLE
WH Y
T, Y
HAVE TCES  IS S,E HINGERES
COD THURSE ORGANIZED AND
THAT WHAT IN
MOVE FORWARD.
THE RUSSIANS ARE THERE BECAUSE
THE REASON THAT ANT T OW
FIGHTIOROI
DO UNDERSTAND WHAT Y'RFIGHTING
PROTECTING YOURSELF AND YOUR
COMRADES, LL IMUCH MORE IMPRES G
TO FIGHT FOR.
N E OMHEM DON'LIN' WHAT THEIR MS
EXACTLY OING IT LEY VERSUS HE W
T HAVING T
, ORGANIZATIONAL AND THE -- WHAT
INST'S
YOU HAVE AEA LCOMMAND STRUCTURE
DIEN WHAE RUSSIA
THEY GIVLOWEST EEL Y TO DO THGS
THE IAO .THE DOCTRINE IN ESSENC
WHICH MEANS ONLYOP GETS TO
OING ON ANHO
FROMRWARD.
U DON'T DO ANYTHING AND THAT'S
TROOPS ITHCH A
CTT REALLYLAKNOW, THEY'R A CERTH
FORWARD, DOING IT, YESAI
WESTERN ASEAVE,
IVES IN MIND BUT
IT R THE
CAGETEC ND TAKGIC OBJECTIVES IN
LLO NO
A  THIS OWUC C ONE ND THE ONES A
THE UKRAINIANS H
LAABLE TO RETAKENS AOW SAI WE'L
THIS IS ATHE RUSSIANS ARG
WARNING FROM ON HIESE RUSSIA
MILI,  KEEP TH
DECAPITATING THENG OUT UKRAINECE
BUT THAT BECOMES REALLY
UNREALISTIC GIVEN THE UKRAINIAC'
KRHAVE
VERY CTHOUGH.
THEY'VE GOT MOMENTUM ON R
SIDE BHE
ECT FIGHT THET HAVESOME OTHE TS
THAT IMPACT MILITARY READINESS
THE RUSS GTI ON FROH KORER
THAT'S AT
THEY'RE GETTING DRESRO
RA OHEY DON'T HAVE THENES THAT .
BUKRAINIANS   THEIR FORMEE WAROA
BORDAND THAT'S WHA
PATHINK WICE
JEN THEHIR HAPPENED, AT, SINT
AGO,E E MAGIC WALL
AND THOUGHT KYAS GO N ND
, I INK ANY OF UD HAVE WHERED N
PEL
THUTNOBODY TUGDID NOT
THINK THEYOU
RSIANS TO THIS
NT SO ON ONENIAN